all right before we get started i want
to thank the sponsor of this video this
video is brought to you by audible
audible the audiobook service that is
the place for you to listen to timothy
zahn's heir to the empire if you want to
listen to a
star wars sequel trilogy that fans
pretty much unanimously love may have
been wiped from official cannon
but it's not dead not yet and audible
has recently launched their new audible
plus plan with audible plus you get full
access to their audible plus catalog
which is filled with not just audiobooks
but podcasts select originals ad-free
versions of popular shows as well as
exclusive series and with the season of
giving being
upon us once again santa john's is here
to save you money click the link below
or text john's to 500 500 to get audible
plus for 4.95 a month for your first six
months after that it's just 7.95 a month
and that monthly membership gives you
access to download stream
otherwise listen to the audio books
podcasts originals that are included in
the audio plus plan so again text jones
to 500 500 or click the link below
to get started and once again thank you
to audible for sponsoring this video as
always i do appreciate it right now we
talk about the continuing adventures of
mando
and baby yoda the cutest life form ever
thought of in the galaxy far far away on
this week's adventure of the mandalorian
there's this facility
that has some imperial stragglers and is
kind of a problem so carl weathers is
like you help us take that thing out and
we're kind of done with the empire here
forever will be a legit establishment so
he's like all right mandalorian is a
video game it's a star wars video game
do you know how it goes you have this
one thing to do it sounds simple enough
it sounds like a pretty
a to b kind of thing then you run into
someone who's like i have answers
can you help me out with that thing
first you're like a side quest
fine that formula is mmo any number of
sandbox games
and mandalorian however the side quests
are actually pretty cool in these last
couple episodes that the mandalorians
found a stride here first of all in this
one they go to the facility it's a
pretty sweet shootout that happens there
sweet shootout at the base there's this
chase sequence that's pretty exciting
carl weathers actually directed this
episode too so he's like as the director
i want to do baby talk to baby yoda come
on have you seen those eyes which
confession
i would make the same deal i'd do the
same thing i do think upon them going to
that base at imperial base
they totally tricked the amphibious dude
you know that guy that was in the pilot
episode mendo freezes him you think all
right that's the last we're ever gonna
see that guy but it's not he's working
off his debt to carl weathers
which that's not his name grief carga
where did he come up with these names
that's a pretty sweet name though like
for his job but yeah grief and cara dune
were like hey amphibious guy you want to
drive us to this imperial base
and grief keeps telling him hey i'll
knock years off of your sentence you
know
centuries decades i think i was like all
right finally like help us out with the
door and he's like no
i'll knock more time off fine and
they're like come on in he's like hell
no they're like well
the lava tides are gonna come in so
you're gonna die so you might as well
which means they obviously knew about
the lava tides and that he would die if
he stayed in the car
and so what they just didn't tell him
until now that is some grade a
trickery right there that's like
hollywood style trickery they're like
i'll come inside you know lava tides
there's probably gonna be a fire fight
in there we might need a meat shield you
don't know
i was like if this guy dies they're the
biggest dicks ever he didn't die so
i guess it's fine doesn't change the
fact that they tricked him into going
into
mortal danger but at the end we have
some hooks and that's what i'm saying is
that mandalorians found its stride among
the mmo formula it has going on here
it's like hey let's peek in on the
imperials see what they're doing see
what moff gideon's up to
leave the audience with some intrigue
and let the youtube videos of theorizing
flow what's that whole intrigue of
what's going on what might be going on
theorizing about what might be going on
that's a big part of the star wars
experience for me i'm actually
really interested about what's going on
because you've learned some things in
here baby yoda they start talking about
baby
i mean they never obviously they don't
say baby yoda because that's what we
call the child but i guess they have a
blood sample but
baby yoda's a baby so they couldn't take
too much blood so they need the host at
first i was like maybe baby yoda's not
even a clone what if yoda and yadle just
got
busy they seem to want baby yoda's blood
they want to sample
from him or her what if baby yoda is not
actually a clone of yoda
what if baby yoda is a clone of yattle
and it's actually baby yattle we've been
saying it wrong all this time
whoa what a twist so in a world of
theorizing as i'm theorizing the last
shot it zooms out and there are these
scientists in this room and it looks
like at first i was like are those
droids they kind of look like droids
because their arms were kind of stiff at
angles
they look like droids uh outfits or
clones i don't know which
i didn't fully know what i was looking
at but if we're just theorizing here it
looks like they want baby yoda's blood
and they want to harvest a sample from
baby yoda they probably want the
midichlorians from baby yoda's blood in
which case they might want to make force
sensitive super soldiers for their
empire so they can come back on top i
mean in a world where what we know for
certain about jedi blood is that
there are midichlorians in there and
that's a physical thing in theory you
could
weaponize that and use it to your own
evil ends at first i was thinking you
can't do an army of baby yodas because
i'm doing the math right if i'm
ballparking it you can take the galaxy
back in
a few hundred years but they could do
that age acceleration thing
that they did with the clone troopers i
don't know if it'll still take 100 years
i don't know if it's
percentage of lifetime so it might still
take a while but if you could accelerate
it to have a clone army of
yodas in no time an army of force
powerful yoda warriors all at your
disposal all 100 loyal to you that could
[ __ ] some [ __ ] up or they're going to
use baby yoda's dna to fill in the gene
sequence gaps to their
palpatine club i hope they don't tie it
into that so we'll see where it goes but
these last couple episodes they've
definitely been
building to something that's what i like
about them i thought this was a great
episode
but more than just you know it's it's
like the flash and excitement the chase
sequences how to phrase it i mean it's
fine it's entertaining but it's not
nearly as engaging to me as the intrigue
of like why do they want baby yoda why
do they want us blood what are they
doing with that
are they making clones are they fusing
midichlorians with troops or something i
don't know could all be [ __ ] it
could be like
you're overthinking it youtube guy i
very well could be
i'm just saying that intrigue is more
engaging to me the engagement of
lore and motivation than a firefight
just is i like seeing it in this episode
like seeing it in the last episode hope
they keep it up but most importantly
baby yoda the child couldn't go with
mando so
he left baby yoda in the one place more
treacherous than an imperial base
public education i did find it
interesting that
among all the kids in this school there
were no like
alien kids they're all human kids the
school being full of only human kids
and suspiciously close to an imperial
outpost could only mean one thing it's
an imperial school
he left baby yoda at an imperial school
know your surroundings man
oh my god all right so this week's
episode of the mandalorian mandalorian
season two episode
four four now that's like half over i
say like half over because i don't know
if they're going to 10
but if they're going to a it's half over
or you can also call it chapter 12. have
you seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]